the 2018 election has been described as
a blue wave but it was also a pink one
on Thursday a record 102 women were
sworn in as members of the US House of
Representatives nearly one quarter of
the total membership in the Texas county
that includes Houston the trend may have
been most apparent that's where nineteen
african-american women ran for
judgeships under a common campaign theme
together they made history and are about
to make some big changes
it was a sweeping decision 2018 win for
African American women in Harris County
this is really historic it is we put in
the work on the campaign trail we were
definitely vocal we were definitely
present we were definitely there and
maybe we're just a little bit more
noticeable Erika Hughes Jermaine Tanner
and Latasha Lewis Payne were part of a
movement that flipped the Harris County
Courthouse is blue non black women yes
we're voting for you yes
millennial whites yes Hispanics what
does that tell you it tells me that
Texas in Harris County is ready to
embrace the the diversity that we have
in our state and and not only to embrace
it but to recognize the importance of it
the 17 newly elected judges stomped on
platforms promising perspective and
fairness when we talk about making sure
that people walk into the courtroom and
whether they are represented by the
highest paid lawyer which I've been or a
pro bono lawyer which I've been that
they are going to get the the very best
opportunity for justice to get their
vote candidates first had to capture
voters attention in a race with few
stars little money and narrow appeal we
looked at each other and realized wow
it's 19 of us we need to embrace the
significance of having so many of us so
why not sure I knew a very specific look
for the picture that we want it entered
Alice Jones a political strategist for
Harris County Democratic Party he
arranged the photo shoot that produced
this snapshot
it looked like a vanity fair' fun is
what it looked like nobody wanted to see
the stuffy you know stand there and
that's not what people wanted to see
they wanted to see real people and they
wanted to see the power and the strength
of black women and that's what that
image portrayed the combination of that
picture and three little words black
girl magic micro magic went viral a
couple of local rappers here in Houston
Piper's rappers and then a few actors
and comedians started posting it the
hashtag isn't new it's promoted black
female pride across social media for
years but as a slogan for a political
campaign it was lightning in a bottle
Kamala Harris when she posted our
picture on her Instagram page that was
amazing amazing you saw 19 qualified
african-american women on the ballot I
think that motivated our community to
get out and vote the nation's eyes are
on Texas and I think that means that
they're on Harris County with more than
four and a half million residents Harris
County is bigger in population than 14
states and boasts both racial and
economic diversity still it accounted
for one-fifth of all the Texas children
locked up in the state's juvenile
prisons in 2017 Democrats in Harris
County won on reforming that system
which now faces multiple discrimination
lawsuits one report found that hundreds
of people are jailed on minor offenses
every day because they can't afford to
make bail 53 percent of them are
detained for more than seven days I was
pretty pretty vocal and pretty adamant
about changing the way business is done
Judge Mark Carter an african-american
Army veteran considered himself a
progressive reformer I was involved in
starting the first mental health courts
I was active in starting the first
public defender's office in Houston but
says he lost on election day because
he's a Republican when a litigant comes
into the courtroom they want to know you
know is this judge fair they don't they
don't care if you're Republican or
what we should be is independent while
applauding the new female block Carter
says moderate voices like his were
drowned out because of straight ticket
voting choosing all candidates of one
party by simply checking one box let's
be honest
isn't this straight ticket voting
something new no no absolutely not
Republicans have have benefited from
that for the last twenty years and
before that Democrats and so the bottom
line is that we're selecting our judges
based on party
the irony is straight ticket voting in
Texas will end before the 2020 elections
Harris County Civil District Court
judges Latasha Lewis pain this new slate
of judges was sworn in on New Year's Day
[Applause]
in the end we are going to put in the
work a lot of judges win get on the
bench and you won't see them again until
election time or election season we want
to stay in the community and as long as
we do that and keep the community
engaged about what we're doing in our
courts I think that that would make a
difference a lot of reaction folks want
to see what they're going to do you talk
to them and they have a plan and they're
moving forward there's some very
impressive women and and I'm you know I
don't know if people know how hard it is
to flip jump chips because they're far
down on the ballot well don't bail out
of a pension you know so that's a major
social media to that we always think
about but it's right there in their
hands learned so much on this story did
not know that Houston did not have a
public defender's office before 2011
whoa knew that